Traduttore: Felice Ferrara
Revisore: Martina Pia Ruino
Buonasera,
in genere faccio un gioco.
Alzi la mano chi non ha mai sentito la parola bitcoin,
però siete tanti.
Vi posso dire che la blockchain è la tecnologia
che fa funzionare i bitcoin.
Ed è una tecnologia che oggi viene già
adottata da IBM, da Microsoft,
e da altre importanti istituzioni,
anche banche.
Scopriamo perché.
Innanzitutto scopriamo perché mi occupo
di blockchain.
Beh, la mia storia comincia abbastanza
indietro nel tempo.
Ho iniziato a usare il computer quando
avevo sei anni,
ho iniziato a scrivere, a digitare
comandi, diciamo,
una volta si scrivevano i comandi,
si interagiva con il computer tramite
interfaccia testuale.
Beh, quindi era un linguaggio, io
parlavo con il computer.
Ed era un linguaggio che mi piaceva,
attualmente,
perché quello che gli dicevo di fare
lo faceva il computer,
e quindi era prevedibile, in un certo
senso
lo preferivo quasi al mondo degli adulti.
Questa prevedibilità oggi è utilizzata
in moltissimi campi.
Siamo andati su marte,
con questa prevedibilità, abbiamo
scattato delle foto.
Questa prevedibilità permette a
determinate piattaforme di fare delle cose
che gli umani una volta facevano a mano.
Perché le facciamo fare alle macchine?
E perché è impossibile tornare indietro?
Perché quando un umano prende una
decisione,
non sappiamo mai che cosa accade in
quelle che chiamiamo la scatola nera,
quindi non sappiamo mai se un umano
effettivamente sta per compiere
quello che invece una macchina o un computer
fa perché gli abbiamo detto di farlo.
Quindi, in un certo senso,
la prevedibilità dei computer sta
supplendo all'imprevedibilità delle persone.
Ora facciamo un esempio,
che non c'entra nulla con i computer,
va indietro nel tempo.
Immaginiamo che ci sono due cacciatori,
un cervo, e due lepri.
Questi due cacciatori se collaborano,
possono portare a casa il cervo,
lo possono cacciare, ma se non collaborano
possono prendere soltanto la lepre,
una per uno.
Ora immaginiamo questa scena,
sono il cacciatore,
sto cacciando il cervo insieme all'altro
cacciatore ma non lo vedo,
non posso comunicare, se faccio rumore
il cervo scappa.
mi si para davanti la lepre, cosa faccio?
E sopratutto, cosa penso che farà l'altro
cacciatore nella mia stessa situazione?
Questa risposta viene dalla teoria
dei giochi.
La teoria dei giochi è un qualcosa che è
concreta nella nostra vita quotidiana,
la usiamo tutti i giorni anche
senza saperlo.
Per esempio quando prendiamo l'automobile,
scegliamo la strada che pensiamo sia meno
trafficata
o immaginiamo quante persone
come noi faranno quella strada.
E su questa base immaginiamo quanto tempo
ci vorrà per raggiungere la meta.
La teoria dei giochi in un certo senso
cerca di portare ordine
nell'imprevedibilità della nostra vita
quotidiana e umana.
Perché questa imprevedibilità,
in un certo senso, può essere pericolosa.
Le persone che girano con una pistola,
Perché si gira con una pistola
negli Stati Uniti?
E sopratutto, l'altro cacciatore dopo che,
dopo che abbiamo sparato alla lepre,
- perché la teoria dei giochi dice
che noi spariamo alla lepre,
non ci importa niente dell'altro
caccciatore e del cervo. -
è armato e ha il fucile carico
ed è imprevedibile.
Cosa potrebbe succedere?
L'imprevedibilità è anche molto costosa,
immaginate le persone che si mettono al
volante dell'automobile avendo bevuto.
Vediamo le macchine in giro,
camminiamo nel traffico,
non sappiamo l'altra persona che
cosa sta per fare.
Potremmo pensare che quindi la teoria dei giochi
spiega in un certo senso tutte le situazioni di imprevedibilità, non è così.
l'imprevedibilità umana è anche controversa,
perchè non sempre le persone fanno quello
che è più conveniente per loro stessi.
Immaginate chi combatte
per i diritti umani.
Immaginate tutti quelli che
svelano le informazioni che vanno
contro i loro interessi personali.
Quindi significa che c'è una parte
di questa imprevedibilità,
di cui comunque ne abbiamo bisogno,
altrimenti saremmo tutti robot.
Ok, guardiamo avanti.
Parliamo finalmente di Bitcoin
e di Blockchain.
Il Bitcoin com'è stato già accennato è
questa convenzione matematica
che permette di scambiarsi valore, denaro
senza bisogno di banche,
senza bisogno di stati.
È un protocollo che gira su i dispositivi
che un po' tutti possediamo,
un po' come il TCP/IP
il protocollo alla base di Internet.
lo utilizziamo tutti i giorni.
lo utilizziamo tutti i giorni
senza saperlo.
Beh, la tecnologia della blockchain ha
delle caratterisitche comuni
con questo tipo di scenario.
Perché oggi a causa dell'imprevedibilità
ci affidiamo a delle strutture
di questo tipo.
Ovvero, un punto centrale di cui tutti
quanti ci fidiamo, ci conviene fidarci,
le banche, gli stati,
i quali si fanno carico di garantire
che se sparo alla lepre e non sparo
al cervo la dovrò pagare,
ma il prezzo che tutta la collettività
deve pagare per questo tipo di comodità
è che quel punto centrale controlla tutto,
cacciatori, lepri, cervi, fucili,
tutto quanto.
Questa è la Blockchain.
Ora, come potete notare,
sono tutti puntini piccoli,
perché la blockchain siamo
tutti quanti noi, potenzialmente.
Com'è possibile quindi che ci sia
una rete che non ha bisogno
di un punto centrale che
controlli tutto quanto.
Beh, ci pensano i computer, ci pensa la
prevedibilità dei computer.
Perché il Bitcoin è un protocollo
matematico che scrive su
questo registro distribuito,
condiviso da tutti quanti,
quelle che sono le regole del gioco.
Scrive su questo registro distribuito che
se io sparerò alla lepre
anziché sparare al cervo,
sarò multato dal sistema.
Ok, manca l'ultimo passaggio.
Chi è che fa rispettare le regole?
I computer.
Con la blockchain, noi parliamo
direttamente
con un dispositivo che possediamo.
con il nostro puntino, con il nostro nodo.
In pratica noi siamo una fusione tra uomo
e macchina grazie alla blockchain,
e quindi cosa succede?
Che il cacciatore affiderà a garanzia,
a riscatto, una lepre al computer
il quale sarà istruito per dare questa
lepre all'altro cacciatore se io decido
di non rispettare le regole del gioco.
In questo modo ci troviamo di fronte a
un sistema che non ha bisogno
di un anello centrale, ma ha bisogno
di una rete distribuita in cui
tutti quanti, se vogliono, possono
partecipare, devono mettere a garanzia
una lepre ma in cambio ricevono un cervo.
Beh, conviene a tutti, no?
Per il cervo la situazione è cambiata.
Siamo di fronte a una situazione in cui
mentre il cervo arrivava a fine giornata
e si guardava il tramonto,
Beh, adesso i due cacciatori sanno bene
che gli conviene cacciare il cervo,
perché se decidono di sparare alla lepre
gli costerà una lepre,
quindi quella lepre verrà lasciata in pace.
Ma sopratutto, quelli che ancora non sono
entrati nel sistema, avranno interesse
a cacciare solo la lepre.
Prenderne una, metterla a garanzia nel
sistema e cominciare a partecipare al
gioco che mette a disposizione un cervo.
Ora, c'è anche un altro problema per
il cacciatore disonesto.
Se alla fine io sparo sempre alla lepre,
e ci rimetto sempre una lepre
gli altri non vogliono più cacciare con
me e quindi anche al cacciatore
conviene rispettare le regole, senza che
sia costretto, è teoria dei giochi,
non gli conviene.
Questo significa che la blockchain è un
gioco a cui noi non possiamo imbrogliare.
È un gioco con cui si possono stravolgere
completamente quelli che sono
gli equilibri nella teoria dei giochi
di Nash.
Possiamo avere degli equilibri nuovi,
degli equilibri dove la cooperazione
è spinta dalla convenienza economica.
Ma una convenienza economica che non è
guidata centralmente.
È una convenienza economica che è guidata
dal cacciatore che con noi quella mattina
si è alzato e andrà a prendere un cervo.
Quindi è una forma di fiducia soltanto
nei confronti dell'altro,
ma è una forma di fiducia in cui sappiamo
che all'altro non converrà imbrogliare
o semplicemente sparare a questa lepre.
Ora arriviamo al punto.
Abbiamo già tutto.
Prima si parlava del Pantheon,
dei miracoli.
In tasca noi abbiamo uno smartphone.
Uno smartphone è già oggi forse la
principale fonte di informazione
per la nostra vita quotidiana,
ce lo abbiamo in tasca.
Ora immaginiamo se lo smartphone ci
dicesse che dobbiamo fare quella strada,
perché se facciamo quella strada ci sarà
meno traffico per tutti.
Immaginiamo che lo smartphone ci dica
cosa ci conviene fare
perché abbiamo lasciato a garanzia
qualcosa, non una lepre probabilmente,
ma qualcosa che abbia un valore economico.
Una garanzia, una scommessa contro noi
stessi, rispetto al sistema,
che ci comporteremo in un certo modo e
tuteleremo l'interesse cooperativo
di tutto quanto il sistema, perché
semplicemente sappiamo che a noi
conviene fare così e agli altri che
partecipano al sistema conviene fare così.
Pertanto, sappiamo che a quel cervo
gli spariamo, ma dobbiamo fare attenzione,
è un momento cruciale, dobbiamo fare
attenzione perché siamo in un momento
in cui i computer potrebbero il potere di
governare le nostre decisioni.
Ma, come dicevamo prima, possiamo
scegliere a quale sistema
a quale blockchain aderire, quindi
possiamo sccegliere di aderire a una
blockchain che non costa troppo o
che non ci costringe troppo.
Il paradosso è che una blockchain...
ci va bene una blockchain che non ci
costringe troppo se non siamo troppo
selfish, egoisti.
Quindi la blockchain non ha soltanto il
potere di pilotare le nostre decisioni
nel modo giusto, ma anche il potere di
costringere ancora di più
chi è più selfish e più attento al valore
economico di quello che fa.
Perché nella nostra blockchain dobbiamo
sempre essere liberi
di avere il cervo davanti, abbassare
il fucile e non sparargli.
Grazie.